his new film the way back is about a
quarterback in year 20 trying to get
back to his favorite team in New England
he's Ben Affleck how are you Ben my bad
I'm sorry it's about you it's about you
playing a basketball coach that's about
a guy who was the basketball star high
school yep fallen on hard times
goes back coaches his old high school
team and kind of learns to re-engage in
life gets a lot out of the players they
get a lot from him
so drama but it avoids a lot of the
cliches it's very it's hard to compete
with the drama unfolding into England
but so before we get to that real quick
what did you learn about coaching Ben
obviously you get into all your roles
you've been you've been there done that
about a lot of stuff but what did you
learn about basketball coaching
throughout this process here honestly
like the coaching thing was the was the
scariest part for me because I've never
done it before right I'm basketball not
even really the sport I know the best so
I you know and now it's just the
familiarity that fans have with sports a
big you know 48 60-inch flat screens
that are behind the scene coverage and
the interviews and all that stuff that
we just can recognize authenticity more
you know like you can't be you know back
when I was a kid you could you could
have major league and it seemed like
Corbin Bernsen maybe could play third
base right you know now we just know
what looks what looks real and what
doesn't and this was the acting I was
really excited about and I I felt
confident about that but I felt very
insecure about like how am I gonna come
up with a coach so I went around I went
to this high school matter day in
Southern California big powerhouse
big-time we'll talk to the players and
coaches there and watched a lot of film
and I guess what I learned is that what
I really learned is that you get a lot
more leeway but swearing at the reps and
I thought you like you know one or two
things they bounce you know these guys I
mean Bobby Knight spent the whole time
on the side it was amazing yeah you know
like the degree to which you could
apparent you can apparently swear at
referees and it's permitted the way back
in theaters near you starting on
Ben Affleck few more minutes left with
him here on the Rich Eisen show alright
Ben do you think Tom goes back to New
England what do you think I give you the
floor what do you think I'm gonna
hesitate to make a prediction okay where
did you say you did a poll and you
thought the majority that people thought
he would wind up in Tennessee if he
doesn't say yeah cuz apparently he and
Edelman were uh and Jimmy Fallon were
all at a Syracuse new North Carolina
game and somebody shot of a photograph
or took a video of Edelman facetiming
with Vrabel at the game well they're
friends I mean yeah I wouldn't say that
necessarily I mean obviously Tom you
know wouldn't want to like tip his hand
for sure and and I obviously hope that
he stays in New England I mean look at
the amazing success they've had I'll
still be a Tom Brady fan if he doesn't
but I think he's a great guy and a great
competitor and a you know great the
greatest quarterback ever I have to
think that it really the ball is in the
court of the Patriots you know what I
mean like I think if they make I don't
know this I don't have any inside
information at all judges but I would
think like if I owned that team I would
say all right look look what somebody
else offering you know you know will
compete with looking bull equal that and
I I would guess that they did that if
they really made those commitments you
know that that he would I would think he
would say you know I I don't really know
any anything ya know nobody knows
honestly truly nobody knows it is all
just that's why we're reading into a
face time you know what I mean like
nobody nobody has any idea what it is I
can't imagine it for the Raiders I
Tennessee has a good obviously a great
running back you know great offensive
line I mean that in me knows very well
that's a good guess you know I San Diego
may be I mean it just but I would think
that like when you look at all those
other options none of them would be as
appealing as like you know you still
have Belichick coaching you have a team
community that loves and supports you
and like you know you know staying kind
of familiar with what you're familiar
with it seems to be the most appealing
thing to me all other things being equal
but who knows
alright well so the way back you know
sometimes you do the part yeah exactly
no no and that's in and
and Brett is still beloved in Green Bay
so you can go home again as in a way he
leaves New England I mean I have friends
from home who like will email me
privately and be like I'll become a
judge as bad if you just stand here you
know I don't you know but you know
people love him that much I think you
know he's definitely not going to
alienate people you know he's his life
and yeah he's TV 12 hey Ben I'm up
against as they say the end of the radio
hour I'd love to have you back on and
have a much longer conversation but
congrats on the way back it's a really
neat moment you got it you got it thanks
the call Ben you take care thank you
about that's a Ben Affleck you're on the
Rich Eisen show